bonjour à tous merci et de nous
retrouver sur public sénat le sommet
européen de ce soir s'annonce décisif
les états membres doivent en effet se
mettre autour de la table pour trouver
un accord sur le sauvetage de la grèce
malgré des intérêts et une vision
divergent l'enjeu est simple il faut
sauver l'euro la monnaie unique
les états membres doivent donc trouver
un accord sur l'effacement de la dette
grecque la recapitalisation des banques
ou encore le renforcement du fesf le
fonds européen de stabilité financière
s'il n'y a pas d'accord et bien c'est la
monnaie unique qui pourrait être menacée
dans ce contexte les sénateurs ont
auditionné hier jean leonetti ministre
des affaires européennes sur l'échec du
premier sommet européen qui s'était
tenue le 23 octobre dernier
c'est donc cette audition que je vous
propose de revoir ce matin bonne matinée
à tous monsieur le ministre
cher président raoul chers collègues je
voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
monsieur le ministre à avoir maintenu
cette audition elle devait être une
audition poste conseil européen et elle
est devenue une audition entre deux
réunions du conseil européen celle de
dimanche et celle de demain qui sera
particulièrement importante en quelque
sorte vous venez nous voir durant une
suspension de séance
il y aura forcément un écart grand ou
petit entre ce que nous voudrions savoir
est ce que vous allez nous dire puisque
tout n'est pas arrêté je dirais même que
c'est l'intérêt de notre réunion de ce
soir
cependant reporter cette audition
n'aurait pas été une bonne solution
puisque le calendrier n'était pas
propice avec une période ferry fériés
suivi presque immédiatement du g20 m
conserver le calendrier prévu et est
donc la meilleure solution même si ce
n'est pas une solution idéale
je donne la parole maintenant au
président raoul qui copréside cette
réunion conjointe de la commission des
affaires européennes et de la commission
de l'économie du développement durable
et de l'aménagement du territoire
oui merci monsieur le président sutour
c'est une des premières en tous les cas
d'avoir une audition commune avec la
commission des affaires européennes je
pense que ce sera pas la dernière dans
le contexte que nous connaissons
monsieur le ministre nous avons déjà eu
le 11 octobre dernier un débat préalable
au conseil européen initialement prévu
d'ailleurs les 17 et 18 octobre et
finalement repoussé au 23 octobre
vous venez aujourd'hui comme l'a dit le
président sutour tout de suite dans une
supension suspension de séance enfin
entre de vendre nos deux commissions et
je remercie en tous les cas le président
de la commission des affaires
européennes d'associer la commission des
affaires économiques
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable de nous présenter
en faites ce que vous pouvez considérer
comme des conclusions provisoires
si bien provisoire de ce conseil
européen mais je crois que cette
audition doit aussi être en place est
replacée dans le contexte la crise
financière majeure que traverse l'europe
à travers la spéculation sur les dettes
souveraines que les dirigeants européens
ne semblent pas à l'heure actuelle je
mets entre guillemets pouvoir arrêter
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression qu'on court après un métro
ken toujours une rame d' avance par
rapport à nos décisions
j'ai pas dit un tramway monsieur roland
riches il faut replacer les décisions
prises par le conseil avec les
négociations en cours des sommets de la
zone euro celui du 23 octobre qui n'a
pas abouti celui annoncé du 26 mai qui
lui n'a pas le droit d'échouer
que pouvez-vous nous dire sur les points
d'accord et ceux restant négociations
entre les dirigeants de la zone euro
le conseil ecofin du 26 doit aussi
aboutir sur des mesures relatives au
secteur bancaire
qui seront reprises lors du sommet de la
zone euro le même jour il ya deux de
choses le même jour le 26 quelle
qu'elles sont elles et quelles en sont
les conséquences pour les banques
françaises
on vient d'en d'auditionner monsieur de
romanet concernant la caisse des dépôts
et ses relations avec dexia la banque
postale et c'est un certain remue ménage
qui se produit dans le domaine en tous
les cas des crédits aux collectivités
locales puisque c'est ce qui nous
préoccupe est de plus qu'en est il du
renforcement des moyens du fonds
européen de stabilité financière et de
ses liens avec la banque centrale
européenne et s clef s que les positions
réellement évoluer autrement dit il y
at-il une possibilité trouver un
compromis le 26 donc
et ensuite est-ce que vous avez une idée
des efforts supplémentaires quand
demandera le 26 à la grèce mais aussi à
l'italie
et pourquoi pas par effet de
contamination éventuellement la france
merci monsieur le ministre
messieurs les présidents mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
merci de m'accueillir dans cette
audition dans laquelle vous l'avez bien
compris je suis dans une période
d'interruption de séance où deux mi
temps encore qui me semble que si
c'était une mi temps la première
mi-temps a quand même apporté un certain
nombre d'événements qui permettent à la
deuxième d'aboutir plus facilement
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit les yeux du
monde entier sont tournés vers cette
réunion du conseil vers ses conclusions
avec des mots qui ont été puisées dans
l'univers dramatique puisque le
président breton de paye rappelé que
c'était le rendez-vous de la dernière
chance et que nous avons sans regarder
le rendez-vous de la dernière chance
obligatoirement comme une échéance
obligatoire le sentiment que l'avenir de
l'europe
l'avenir de l'equilibre monétaire
mondial se joue effectivement dans les
jours qui viennent dans ce contexte vous
le savez plusieurs sujets ont été
évoqués mais je m'attends bien sûr ce
que les informations concernant la
stratégie économique pour la zone euro
et la croissance sont les éléments les
plus importants que vous attendez par
ailleurs on a évoqué le g20 on a évoqué
d'urban et dans ce domaine un certain
nombre d'avancées ont été faites par
ailleurs aussi les conclusions du
conseil
faire général a contribué à faire en
sorte que la croissance puisse être au
rendez-vous de l'europe et que l'on y
développe les outils nécessaires pour
faire en sorte que la crise monétaire
que nous traversons une fois passé nous
ne serons pas dans une politique
uniquement de rigueur mais en même temps
une politique d'avenir et de
compétitivité pour la zone euro et pour
l'ensemble de l'europe
mais si vous le permettez je vais me
limiter à au sujet qui nous préoccupe
tous et qui est la finalisation d'un
accord autour de la crise monétaire
d'abord la grèce côté positif et il n'y
a plus de débat pour le fait de savoir
si on abandonne ou non la grèce l'europe
n'abandonne pas la grèce la grèce ne
soit pas l'euro aujourd'hui ces choses
là apparaissent comme des évidences
elle n'était pas aussi évidente lorsque
il y avait là aussi une divergence entre
la position française qui prenait la
solidarité avec la discipline et la
position allemande qui prônait la
rigueur qui tarde à se trouver dans des
situations d'abandon de la grèce il faut
être conscient de plusieurs choses
le premier c'est que le peuple grec est
en grande souffrance et le deuxième
c'est que un plan de rigueur stricte de
la grèce dans un contexte de mauvaise
organisation pour ne pas dire d'absence
d'organisation de l'administration
fiscale de l'organisation du pays est
associé à une récession profonde ne peut
pas aboutir à ce que la grèce puisse
rembourser dans des délais brefs la
dette qui pèse sur ses épaules
cela veut dire de manière plus claire
que il il faut restructurer la dette de
la grèce
vous le savez lors des précédentes
décisions
l'ensemble de l'institution financière a
accepté de renoncer à 21,5 pour cent de
la dette grecque
les chiffres qui sont avancés
aujourd'hui sont plus élevées à parler
de 40 on a parlé 50 on a parlé de 60
le débat aujourd'hui d'abord avec les
banques puisque cette restructuration se
ferait à partir d'une décision
volontaire du système bancaire et en
même temps sur l'importance de ceux de
cette restructuration pour ne pas
qu'elles apparaissent les mots sont
subtiles comme un défaut ou un événement
de marché et qui amène à ce moment là
soit un effet domino soit une diminution
de notation des banques qui
accepteraient de d'assumer cette
décharge
sur le deuxième point qui l'organisation
du fonds européen de stabilité
financière vous vous en souvenez sur les
à création à l'initiative de la france
vous souvenez de sa souplesse
supplémentaire attise le 21 juillet et
qui a été voté par l'ensemble des pays
et qui a abouti à la fin qui a commencé
par la france et qui a fini par la
slovaquie qui n'a pas été un parcours
sans embûche
rappelons et c'est pas ici que je dois
le faire mais que
il y à 17 et 27 démocraties et que ces
17 et 27 évoquera si on ne peut pas à la
fois reproché à l'europe de décider par
l'intermédiaire de ses parlement sur des
décisions importantes et en même temps
reproché à l'europe de réagir avec
lenteur et donc au bout de ce
cheminement les décisions qui ont été
prises par les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des 21 juillet sont
pleinement en application
c'est dire que le fonds européen de
stabilité financière et opérationnelle
la question de saône opérabilité et que
vous le savez il était doté de 440
milliards d'euros sur des contributions
de l'état et que la dette de la grèce va
probablement amputé cette somme de 130
milliards d'aud ce qui revient à dire
que le fonds européen de stabilité
financière se trouve maintenant à 300
milliards de ses 300 milliards d'euros
sont ils suffisants pour absorber la
dette grecque oui pas inutile de
rappeler que la grèce ça n'est que et ça
n'est pas une insulte pour ce grand pays
qui a marqué notre histoire et notre
démocratie que de dire que c'est 2% à
peine delà du pib de la zone euro et 4 %
de la dette de la zone euro et que donc
ce n'est pas insurmontable pour
l'ensemble des pays de la zone euro
néanmoins dans ce contexte vous le savez
le phénomène de dominos qu'on a connu et
qu'on connaît encore fait que d'autres
grands pays et en particulier celle qui
a été mis sur la sellette par les
marchés financiers et par les agences de
notation l'italie elle est la troisième
puissance économique européenne et que
donc il faut que nous mettions fin à
cette contamination
et pour mettre fin à cette contamination
il faut avoir un fonds européen de
stabilité financière d'un niveau
tellement élevé que
la tentation spéculative s'écrase contre
semur finances
on a parlé de 1000 milliards d'euros on
a parlé de 2000 milliards d'euros ce qui
est important est de savoir comment on
obtient ses sols et vous le savez la
france a été à fouiller une première
hypothèse qui étaie l'hypothèse
d'adosser le fonds européen de stabilité
financière la banque centrale européenne
la banque centrale européenne avait
était seul et peser mes mots mais où
était un peu sorti de l'orthodoxie de sa
mission en rachetant sur les marchés
secondaires des dettes souveraines des
états en difficulté dans ces conditions
l'ensemble des pays il avait accepté la
banque centrale européenne
ce triche il avait accepté à condition
que ce soit une situation transitoire
aujourd'hui le fait d'adosser le fond
européenne sa vie des financières à la
banque centrale européenne met en danger
en mer danger peut remettre en cause
deux éléments d'une part l'indépendance
de la banque centrale européenne à
laquelle bien sûr tout le monde est
attaché la france et l'allemagne
et puis pourrait remettre en cause
l'orthodoxie la lecture orthodoxe des
traités il ferait que le fonds européen
de stabilité financière s'assimilerait
comme le souhaitait la france où comme
l'envisagé la france à une banque
devant ces difficultés juridiques
la france n'a pas renoncé à explorer
cette piste mais a bien compris que à la
fois les autorités allemandes et la
banque centrale européenne était opposée
à cette proposition
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'autres
pistes sont à l'étude
vous les avez vu comme moi dans la
presse l'aide du fonds monétaire
international la création d'un véhicule
particulier destiné à soutenir les
dettes des états souverains dans un
contexte de partenariat avec des fonds
privés et des fonds publics
il faut garder à l'esprit une chose
c'est que il faut trouver un mécanisme
qui puisse lever des fonds sans pour
autant qu'on se trouve avec une
contribution forte des états et si je
regarde les choses du côté français une
forte contribution à l'alimentation de
fonds européen de stabilisation
financière aboutir et forcément une
augmentation de la dette française est
peut-être à fragiliser sa note sur les
marchés financiers et donc l'exploration
aujourd'hui en est à dire pourquoi le
fonds européen ne ne garantirait pas les
dettes souveraines ou les obligations
des pays possédant des dettes
importantes jusqu'à une certaine hauteur
créant un plancher qui garantirait pour
ceux qui s'en ferait acquéreurs la
possibilité au moins d'avoir ce
remboursement de marché qui permettrait
de surmultipliée
le volume du fonds européen stabilité
financière a bien compris que je parle
au conditionnel et que je n'aimais que
des hypothèses puisque là aussi il faut
trouver le mécanisme adéquat qui soit
capable de faire l'effet levier sans
demander une contribution forte des
états avec les inconvénients que cela
pourrait comporter reste la
recapitalisation des banques avec des
éléments qui faisait que les banques
européennes avec soumises à un stress
tests que huit d'entre elles avaient mal
subi
ces tests que l'ensemble des banques
françaises l'avaient réussi de manière
positive et en se souvenant qu'il
s'agissait en fait d'un stress test
comportant une croissance négative de 2
points pendant une période de plus de
deux ans et que les banques européennes
avaient donc globalement bien subi le
test ainsi que toutes les banques
françaises se trouvent que dexia qui est
une situation très particulière vous le
savez avait subi un stress tests qui ne
touchaient pas aux problèmes propres au
fondamental de dexia qui étaient des
emprunts à court terme sur un faible
taux sur des crédits à long terme sur
des taux plus élevés et que elle a quand
même eu des graves difficultés malgré le
fait d'avoir subi un stress tests cela
veut dire en clair que ils conviennent
de revérifier l'ensemble des banques
européennes et pas uniquement celles qui
avaient subi un stress test négatif
par ailleurs et vous l'avez noté ne
recapitaliser que les banques qui
seraient jugées éventuellement fragile
créé là aussi un effet de cible qui fait
que les marchés financiers aurait
facilement identifier les banques
fragiles et aurait pu les mettre en
difficulté c'est la raison pour laquelle
est dans l'idée générale que la réponse
de ce sommet de ces sommet européen doit
être une réponse globale harmoniser et
durable l'idée de recapitaliser
l'ensemble des banques a fait son chemin
le deuxième chemin à la demande de
l'allemagne avec une gêne en contenu en
aucune façon la france c'est que cette
recapitalisation se fasse à partir des
états
se trouve que l' expertise qui est faite
auprès des banques françaises a montré
qu'aucune d'entre elles n'avait besoin
d'une recapitalisation qui ne soit
étrangère à ses fonds propres
vous le savez c'était en fait ça n'est
que de l'anticipation du bâle iii le
bâle iii de vern 2018 faire en sorte
qu'on passait de 7% à 9% de sécurité sur
les fonds propres et aujourd'hui les
banques françaises peuvent assumer cette
augmentation de capital de fonds propres
qui doit tourner autour de environ 10
milliards d'euros et faire en sorte que
donc si on compare l'augmentation des
fonds propres des banques françaises
dans le premier simmel semestre elles
ont réussi à augmenter leurs fonds
propres de 10 milliards d'euros
hélas les forts quand leur demanderez
serait de 10 milliards supplémentaires
si je rajoute que la dette grecque elle
même reconsidérez expose les banques
françaises à 8 milliards d'euros
en gardant l'hypothèse l'hypothèse que
elle serait restructurée à hauteur de
50%
ça veut dire que les banques françaises
subiraient à
une perte de 4 milliards d'euros qui
seraient donc relativement facilement
absorbés par les 10 milliards
supplémentaires plus les 10 milliards
qui ont été acquis pendant le premier
semestre
je rappelle que les banques françaises à
partir de 2008 ont recapitalisé de 50
milliards qu'elles ont remboursé la
dette qu'elle avait vis-à-vis de l'état
par anticipation il ya des taux très
élevés et que donc le système bancaire
français plutôt un système bancaire
français est solide
tant mieux puisque ça voudrait dire ça
voudrait dire j'utilise inconditionnel
que l'état n'aurait pas à contribuer à
la recapitalisation des banques et que
le deuxième volet de l'action ne serait
pas mise en oeuvre le troisième volet de
l'action c'est le fonds européen de
stabilité financière et lui vous l'avez
compris il est plutôt destiné aux
banques grecques les plus exposées à la
dette grecque est incapable de se faire
recapitaliser bien évidemment par l'état
grec
sur les autres points qui ont été
évoqués en dehors de ceux de ce triangle
fort d'abord l'association des 27 au 17
je sais pas ce que le président de la
république française a dit à monsieur
cameron mai
je suppose que c'était à peu près de la
même vague que ce que j'ai dit à mon
collègue en conseil des affaires
générales
il est très difficile de ne pas vouloir
être dans la zone euro et en même temps
d'y être pour être non seulement
informer mais pour participer aux
décisions et donc j'ai dit publiquement
à donington qui est un homme extrêmement
plein d'humour que s'il voulait mieux
connaître la zone euro il fallait qu'il
y rentrer et qu'à ce moment-là il
verrait exactement comment ça s'est
passé il pourrait y participer
totalement est pleinement et le
président fraude peu à la fin à la
conclusion elle dit que il pensait que
les 27 devaient être informés et
impliqué dans les décisions qui devaient
être prises et qu'en aucun cas ils
accepteraient les amendements de la
grande bretagne qui en faisait une
obligation légale
le deuxième point c'est la rigueur
budgétaire la discipline budgétaire tout
le long de cette évolution on a bien
compris que la discipline budgétaire
doit être au coeur de nos politiques
sans pour autant faire de la rigueur un
élément de récession des peuples en
difficulté c'est la raison pour laquelle
le couple franco-allemand réaffirmer sa
solidarité vis-à-vis de l'italie mais en
même temps sa vigilance à vis à vis tu
cette époque prône cette économie
majeure qui doit pouvoir assumer une
gestion rigoureuse permettant justement
de créer la croissance nécessaire qui
risque de lui faire défaut dans les
années à venir
sept éléments amènent à la troisième et
dernier volet que je voudrais évoquer
avec vous c'est l'harmonisation rennes
renégociation des traités
l'allemagne propose que le traité soit
revu avec deux visions une vision qui
serait d'abord une vision de discipline
budgétaire
bien sûr on peut comprendre que
l'allemagne et le peuple allemand soit
inquiet de voir des grands pays à ficher
des dettes importantes et être le
contribuable habituel de ses défauts
c'est la raison pour laquelle
souhaiterait qu'un cadre budgétaire qui
ressemble un peu à la règle d'or
proposée en france ou à d'autres
le système qui ont été mis en place en
allemagne puissent être mis en place
tout en laissant bien entendu dans ce
cadre budgétaire la possibilité à chaque
état de décider de l'organisation et de
la décision de son budget donc de
d'exercer sa pleine souveraineté et il
est bien clair que ça nécessitera ur et
la vigilance qui ferait qui aurait un
contrôle a priori ou a posteriori sous
les budgets des états pour vérifier que
les missions qui ont été les objectifs
qui ont été antérieurement défini
pourrait l'être à posteriori je suis
encore plus dans le conditionnel vous
l'avez compris puisque cette proposition
allemande sa sortie d'un volet que je
qualifierais qualifierait plus de la
relance ou
de l'économie est qui et qui est une
proposition je dirais à d'initiative
française et qui dirait passons à la
gouvernance économique européenne
et si nous constatons que le fonds
européen de stabilité financière
associée au l'évolution vers le
mécanisme européen de stabilité peut à
certains moments être à la limite du
respect des traités profitant d'une
révision des traités pour faire en sorte
que ce gouvernement économique européen
soit réellement mis en place mais le
président de la république a souligné
est il à se re souligné dans la
conférence de presse que c'est un une
étape supplémentaire vers l'intégration
économique et qu'on ne peut pas
envisager cet été cette étape
supplémentaire sent qu'il ya un débat
laissant que les peuples soient associés
à cette évolution avec tous les risques
que cela comporte
j'ai eu tout à l'heure des journalistes
qui me disaient de parler d'europe est
ce que c'est pas dangereux est ce que ça
risque pas d'alimenter le populisme et
l'euroscepticisme
je crois que ça c'est de ne pas parler
de l'europe et de ne pas avancer dans la
démarche
kino qui nous préoccupe tout ce qui
comporte effectivement risques on a tous
un devoir de pédagogie et en même temps
d'afficher un volontarisme le courage et
la lucidité de passer à cette étape
supplémentaire
elle ne peut pas se faire bien entendu
en catimini et non dans un contexte à
court terme
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
position française là aussi est assez
clair utilisons tous les moyens que nous
avons en dehors de la révision des
traités et faisons en sorte qu'on
apporte stabilité avec cesser ses murs
anti spéculation que sont le
renforcement du fonds européen
la recapitalisation des banques et la
restructuration de la dette grecque puis
envisageons plus sereinement la révision
des traités pour passer et fanti
effectivement à une étape supplémentaire
d'efficacité et de discipline donc et
qui allierait bien sûr solidarité et
discipline au sein 2e la gouvernance
économique européens
sachez toutefois qu'il a été acté que
monsieur von roll paye donc présidera
pour les deux ans et demi la zone euro
et en même temps qu on lui on y sera
associée au commissaire chargé des
affaires économiques pour faire en sorte
connaît c'était bloch de gouvernement
économique européen qui puisse un jour
s'organiser et faire en sorte qu'on
puisse utiliser le mot qui ne me choque
pas mais qui peut énerver certains le
fédéralisme économique permettant à ce
moment là d'avoir à la fois la solidarit
solidarité la protection que nous
souhaitons majoritairement voilà les
éléments que j'ai en ma possession et
que je voulais vous livrez je vous
demande bien entendu parce que je suis
allé un peu au delà des devant vous des
des propositions officielles de
considérer que que je n'ai brasser que
des hypothèses et qu'en aucun cas j'ai
fait le prélude d'une décision qui doit
se faire mercredi et comme vous l'avez
souilem seul président à la fois avec
une réunion l'économie finances et avec
une réunion des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement trouve assez votre
attention je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre de votre intervention alors je
vais noter les différentes demandes
attendez je vais d'internement mais
avant je vais donner la parole au
président de la commission des affaires
économiques qu'il ya des précisions à
vous demander si je peux oui c'est bien
dans les hypothèses qui s'ils peuvent
être envisagées demain en tous les cas
dans ces sommets que suri koffi nous par
rapport à la suite logique de ce qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure
l'audition de monsieur de romanet avec
les évolutions des banques
je dirais la recomposition tous les cas
un certain nombre de capitaux avec la
banque postale la caisse des dépôts et
le démantèlement de dexia est question
qui ce qui pourrait se poser suivant
l'une des hypothèse c'est que si on
demande aux banques je dirais de verser
de verser leur écot ou leur quote-part
de 50% sur la dette grecque
comment un certain nombre de banques
sont capables de tenir la route et
qu'elle ait fait éventuelles ceci peut
avoir sur des filiales de banques
françaises qui pourrait par
contamination je dirais touchés
c'est pas notre cette histoire de 50% de
la dette je peux comprendre la logique
du système mais s'il ya des morts enfin
s'il ya des banques qui disparaissent
dans l'histoire qu'est-ce que ça pour
conséquences sur nos banques françaises
dont vous avez dit qu'ils avaient
vérifié tout honorablement les les tests
mais sur une nouvelle dent nouvelle
donne qui n'est pas 2 % de 2 - en pib
là c'est une nouvelle donne ses abords
donné 50 % du net donc c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose que l'hypothèse qui
avait été évoquée lors des tests
globalement monsieur marc qui est le
premier vice président de la commission
des finances
oui merci ce président est merci
monsieur liste de ces précisions nous
apporter le sénat a examiné comme
l'assemblée ces derniers jours la
situation de la société dexia et cette
occasion et à l'issue des différentes
auditions qu'ils n'en ont pu réaliser
nous avons eu le sentiment que la
situation des banques pouvaient se
dégrader à tout instant et à très vive
allure
dès lors qu' on n'est pas sorti
malheureusement des des soubresauts de
cette crise née il ya trois ans et cet
égard sentiment que on est aujourd'hui
entré dans une crise du crédit qui quoi
qu'il arrive dans le règlement du
contentieux présent et des difficultés
présentes va peser certainement sur
l'économie pour plusieurs mois avoir
plusieurs années et ça c'est un souci
d'inquiétude bien dessus bien sûr on
nous tous mais ce qui est aussi un souci
d'inquiétude c'est de constater que ce
qui a été à l'origine de ces crises dont
on voit aujourd'hui les répercussions en
chaîne
c'est là
situation de du secteur financier et et
toute la dérégulation qui a été
constatée et la dérive du capitalisme
financier qui malheureusement l'échelle
de l'europe n'est pas traitée
aujourd'hui puisque jean pierre jouyet
nous a dit récemment que dans le monde
75 % des transactions financières et ça
échappe aujourd'hui à tout contrôle y à
toute régulation
les trois quarts des transactions
financières aujourd'hui ne passe en
aucune façon au travers de ces modes de
régulation mission de mettre en place et
dire si demain d'autres conséquences
peuvent être ressentis j'en reviens à ma
question le ministre puisque vous évoqué
cette possibilité de faire évoluer le
fonds européen sur l'été financière et
vous indiquer qu'ils avaient eu quelques
différences d'appréciation entre
l'allemagne et la france
moi je souhaiterais que vous vous
préciser quelles ont été les motivations
de la france pour l'adossement à la bce
ou la mise en place d'un système de type
bancaire parce que on sait qu'elle est
la conséquence
imaginé par les allemands qui sont très
avertis des risques que peuvent faire
que l'inflation travers leur histoire
est pas si ancienne et qui dès lors
craignent sans doute que l'inflation
soit bien entendu dans la seringue dès
lors que ce dispositif serait orientée
vers la banque est donné à la bce des
moyens d'intervention
qu'est ce qui a motivé que la france
cherche à obtenir que un dispositif de
type bancaire soit mis en place en
complément ou en adossement du fonds de
solidarité c'est une question à laquelle
on aimerait avoir des réponses parce que
c'est un sujet aujourd'hui a du mal à
comprendre les motivations des uns et
des autres monsieur châtillon
est-ce qu'on le connaît ce qu'on a
essayé d'évaluer le montant des
engagements sur l'italie je parle des
banques françaises bien sûr je suis
demandé ce qu il fallait encore une
question et puis vous remercie monsieur
le président c'est miss nous dit que
dans les restaurations va perdre 1 pour
cent cinquante pour cent soixante pour
cent de ce qui est du pas la grèce mais
qu'estime y est en place au niveau de
l'union européenne pour faire en sorte
que l'état grec et des recettes fiscales
il semblerait d'après ce qu'on peut lire
que les contribuables sont tous deux
donné absent que les entreprises depuis
pas vraiment beaucoup d'impôts que
l'église grecque qui paraît-il le plus
grand propriétaire terrien n'en paye pas
non plus alors qu'est ce que l'europe
met en place en grèce au faire en sorte
que ce pays ait des recettes afin
d'honorer le restant de la dette
j'ajouterai une deuxième question chacun
au fond de soi sans que ce cadre un peu
stricte budgétaire est indispensable
dans la mesure où les gouvernements
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche ont
fait preuve d'une certaine légèreté et
même d'absence de mon sens mais en
comment peut-on rendre compatibles ce
cadre rigoureux et un plan de relance
qui forcément hors cadre monsieur dantec
oui c'était pour aller dans le sens de
ce que vient de dire françois mart c'est
à dire que on a l'impression qu'on est
en face de deux crises une crise j'ai
donc aux déséquilibres budgétaires de la
grèce et d'un certain nombre de pays
européens et donc vous vous l'avez dit
même donc on il faut renforcer le fonds
européen de stabilité financière allait
peut-être demain sur une autre
gouvernance et économique et vous dites
mais même latence est je vous cite à la
tentation spéculative doit s'écraser sur
ce mur que serait le fonds européen de
stabilité financière mes donc ça pose
l'autre question ce qui est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait justement par rapport aux
capacités spéculative hostile c'est dire
que on a le conseil européen mais en
alger 20 derrière et si on se contente
de traiter la question du surendettement
mais pas les régulations spéculative
internationale on va courir derrière et
être uniquement en défensive et donc on
voit pas la deuxième partie aujourd'hui
la réponse alors dernière question de
cette première rafale monsieur courteau
oui très rapidement monsieur monsieur le
président en fait après la grèce
l'irlande et le portugal
si j'ai bien compris on a ouvert
dimanche dernier une prochaine
intervention en faveur de l'italie qui
pourrait être menacée par une onde de
choc
alors je crois savoir que le bnp paribas
serait exposé m'attendent y est
particulièrement exposé sur la péninsule
qu'en est il exactement en fait protéger
l'italie troisième économie de l'union
européenne c'est aussi protéger la
france bien sûr d'abord et ensuite la
zone euro deuxième question quand
qu'attend-t-on de l'italie exactement
en contrepartie et rapidement et puis
quelle est actuellement la situation de
la france
monsieur le président d'abord
vous parliez de la dette grecque et de
l' éventualité qui pourrait être
envisagé de la restructurer à hauteur de
50% et des conséquences que cela
pourrait avoir sur les banques
françaises
donc je je je rappelle oui sur les
banques grecques
bien entendu cela les met face à un
séisme
insurmontables et donc la seule
possibilité pour recapitaliser les
banques grecques
c'est le fonds européen de stabilité
financière puisque la fusée à trois
étages que le premier étage c'est la
banque elle même le deuxième étage c'est
les états le troisième étage c'est le
fonds européen de stabilité financière
en ce qui concerne la france les
chiffres ont été redonnés récemment 8
milliards d'euros pour les banques
françaises
4 milliards d'euros donc si l'hypothèse
de 50% a été retenu 4 milliards
largement à la hauteur des banques
exposées donc sur la situation telle
qu'elle se déroulerait ci ont
circonscrit le problème à la grèce le
fonds européen de stabilité financière
est suffisant et les banques françaises
sont recapitalisées de façon autonome
monsieur marc évoqué la situation de
dexia
bien sûr c'est une situation vous le
savez très particulière dans lequel le
mécanisme à la fois très particulière
dans le mécanisme qu'elle utilisait
puisque souvent adossés au franc suisse
est le prêter à long terme avec des
crédits à court terme sur des taux
extrêmement bas donc avec un problème
plus de liquidités que de solvabilité
mais qui à un moment donné en période de
crise fait bien entendu
exploser le système dans sa pré carré
aujourd'hui vous le savez le connaissez
le partenariat belge français et
luxembourgeois aussi sur une filiale le
le l'isolément de la mauvaise dette et
qui se traiterait ensuite de manière
progressive et l'idée majeure de la part
de la france et de la belgique de ne
toucher en aucun cas les gens qui ont
déposé leurs leurs économies et je crois
que ça c'est un élément qui est
totalement hors hors d'eau risque dans
ce contexte vous me posez aussi la
question de savoir comment réguler c'est
une question qui a aussi posé monsieur
dantec
comment on régule quand on a fait tout
ça parce que si la dette
si on réfléchit pourquoi nous sommes
dans cette situation il ya en fait deux
phénomènes conjugués
il ya un phénomène qui n ont pas la
difficulté de l'euro qui est une monnaie
plus forte et plus stable que le dollar
c'est la situation de certaines dette
insoutenable de d'état de la zone euro
et que parallèlement à cette situation
d'endettement en particulier due à
l'émergence justement des pays du même
qualificatif et de la compétitivité
insuffisante de pays qui ont bénéficié
de la zone euro la grèce bénéficie de la
zone euro elle se trouve avec des
crédits aux alentours de 2%
elle a la capacité donc de s'endetter je
deviens facilement qu'elle n'aurait pas
eu si elle s'était trouvé dans une
situation où elle n'était pas protégée
artificiellement par l'euro ensuite elle
se trouve avec une compétitivité
extrêmement faible et au moment de la
crise au moment où on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya un triplement de la dette grecque et
que les comptes qui ont été fournies ne
sont pas un réel et sincère
à ce moment là c'est là que se déclenche
le phénomène donc ça veut dire que en
clair les trois éléments qu'on a évoqué
son insuffisant puisque il faut le
deuxième phénomène qui est la
dérégulation des marchés financiers et
donc là on passe à la fois sur une
stratégie au niveau européen et sur une
stratégie au niveau international et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya une
stratégie dans la stratégie qui consiste
à faire en sorte connaissez de régler
les problèmes européens avant d'aborder
les problèmes du g20 je crois pas à la
théorie de complot et j'ai peu de
tendance à la paranoïa mais je vois bien
que lorsque les banques européennes ont
des difficultés à s'approvisionner en
dollars
il ya peut-être la suspicion d'un
certain nombre de banques françaises vis
à vis du dollar
mais il ya peut-être aussi de la part
d'autres mères une vision qui consiste à
considérer que cette monnaie est en
partie concurrente du dollar et c'est
ainsi et et qu'en même temps elle et
elle est plus forte plus stable et
peut-être même un peu surcoté donc dans
ce contexte il faut qu au niveau du g20
et une prise de conscience qu' il ya une
interdépendance forte et définitive
entre la chine créanciers mais qui n'a
aucun intérêt à voir sa dette s'envoler
dans des faillites d'état et qui a eu
contre contributeurs aussi de la zone
euro les états unis amérique qui n'ont
pas une envie
obligatoire de voir la zone euro
extrêmement forte par rapport au dollar
mais qui n'ont pas non plus intérêt à
voir la zone euro s'effondre et parce
que ça va entraîner ça entraînerait une
une impossibilité de croissance pour eux
donc
le g20 est l'occasion à la fois de
travailler sur ce que vous évoquez que
75% des opérations soit automatisé en
cours nous fait bien comprendre pourquoi
on se trouve dans une situation dans
laquelle phénomène s'amplifie
immédiatement et extrêmement rapidement
le fait qu' il ya des échanges qui se
font à la vitesse de la seconde pour
augmenter la spéculation est aussi un
phénomène qui peut pas être accepté et
sur le plan européen
on voit bien que il faut continuer dans
la voie où on s'est engagés et à dire
taxer les banques
oui pour avoir un élément de
surveillance et et le financer faire en
sorte de limiter les bonus des traders
et faire en sorte connaît une
surveillance macroéconomique des bulles
spéculatives éventuelle à la fois sur le
plan mondial et sur le plan européen
donc l'ensemble de ces mécanismes le g20
viennent coiffer les dispositifs de la
zone euro à condition que le g20 ne soit
pas polluée par une situation qui ne
serait pas réglé dans la zone euro et
qui serait le prétexte au concert
international a accusé l'europe de deux
fautes qu'elle n'a pas au moins
initialement commises
donc il faut absolument régler ce
problème mercredi et dans les jours qui
suivent le mettre en place pour que la
présidence française
en arrivant au g20 puisse affirmer et
pardon de le dire dans un langage un peu
triviale j régler mon problème européen
maintenant je viens vous expliquer
comment il faut que nous régulions
ensemble le problème d'un système
monétaire international qui a perdu
toute règle qui s'est détachée
progressivement de l'économie réelle est
qui
je dirais à c'est tellement autonomiser
virtualisés qu'elle en a perdu à la fois
le sens et qu'elle met en danger
l'économie mondiale sur le jeu chelsea
on repose le problème de l'italie
willy thalys c'est à la fois plus plus
plus volumineux plus important plus fort
et donc plus dangereux
on est dans une économie forte
elle l a pris des mesures
je crois que le message qu'a passé le
président de la république et la
chancelière c'est que on ne peut aider
par l'intermédiaire de la banque
centrale du fonds européen de stabilité
financière auquel l'italie peut avoir
recours que dans la mesure où les
décisions qui ont été prises se mettait
effectivement en route et donc le
passage du verbe l'action est
indispensable pour que la discipline
soit effective que l'ensemble du système
soit consolidée et il n'y a aucune
raison il ya aucune raison qu'on ne
croie pas là l'engagement qu'on ne croie
pas l'engagement et qu'on n'est pas
confiance dans l'engagement de l'italie
qui est une économie forte mais qui est
menacée d'une récession si elle ne prend
pas les mesures qu'elle avait elle prend
pas rapidement les mesures qu'elle avait
initialement annoncé
sur ce montesquiou parle de de la
rigueur et de la relance et l'a
parfaitement raison on a bien vu que la
grèce qui se trouvait à un moment donné
dans une période fin qui se trouve
maintenant dans une période de récession
est dans une période de récession
durable qu'elle a une absence totale
d'organisation administrative et que
donc on ne peut pas à la fois lui
infliger la rigueur et lui demander la
croissance et que la croissance ne peut
pas arriver dans ce contexte la raison
pour laquelle à la fois il ya la
surveillance par la troïka le fonds
monétaire international la banque
centrale européenne et la commission qui
surveille effectivement les avancées les
situation évolutive de la dette grecque
mais il ya aussi
les experts qui viennent un appui non
pas comme des censeurs mais comme des
accompagnateurs de l'organisation
nécessaire de la collecte de l'impôt ne
serait-ce que cela de l'organisation du
cadastre de de la collecte d'une taxe
d'une tva et de la mise en place d
engagement courageux compris la grèce et
vous avez raison de faire ce geste ça va
prendre plusieurs mois voire quelques
années
cela signifie en clair et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut passer à la
restructuration de la dette pour que
l'on puisse faire penser qu'à un moment
donné
la grèce peut revenir sur le sur la
place des marchés financiers ce qu'elle
n'est incapable de faire aujourd'hui
donc la rigueur oui mais la rigueur
surtout dans la capacité à mettre en
place des structures qui permettent la
croissance de demain
le déficit grec 17 milliards la fraude
fiscale 17 milliards dis pas que c'est
le seul pays à avoir une fraude fiscale
un fait à dire mais ni à avoir du
déficit mais les deux chiffres 10 bien
qu' on n'est pas dans une culture du
prélèvement de l'impôt et tous ceux qui
comme le président sont des amoureux de
la grèce comme moi et qui vont
fréquemment se rendent compte que il y a
des habitudes qui ont été prises et qui
sont difficiles à changer
montesquieu disait qu'il était plus
facile de changer les lois que de
changer les moeurs et je crois qu'il
avait si vous voyez la situation grecque
il l'approuverait j'ai répondu à
monsieur dantec
avec l'ap
alors il ya 2 il ya deux éléments les
rendre compatibles
d'une part d'une barre il ya deux façons
de pouvoir travailler d'abord la troïka
surveille l e débloque les fonds
déblocage des 8 milliards donc immédiat
de la sixième tranche
le deuxième volet c'est comment on
relance l'économie grecque
je suis mal exprimé sur dans les pays
majeurs disons de l'europe
on pense cet encadrement règle d'or ou
autre oui admettons que à la suite d
égarement des divers gouvernements en
france par exemple des mauges qui seront
perdus souvent le bon sens pour la
facilité comment peut-on rendre
compatibles cet encadrement qu'on peut
appeler autrement que règle d'or c'est
un encadrement et un plan de relance qui
forcément hors cadre alors je vais
prendre l'exemple de la france et les
deux jambes de la grèce donc pour finir
avec la grèce il ya les milliards qui
sont débloqués par la troïka ça c'est
l'aide
et puis le sixième tranche et puis il ya
les fonds structurels
est ce que au niveau européen il faut
pas commencer à se poser la question de
ne pas retomber dans les travers
antérieur la grèce a bénéficié de fonds
structurels
elle a bénéficié de fonds de cohésion
je dis pas comme at-elle fait je dis
simplement que probablement ils ont mal
été utilisé et peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
les fonds européens dans le cadre du
budget européen
peut-être qu'il faut réfléchir à dire
oui à la cohésion
oui oui à la halle à aux fonds
structurels où il ya l'aide des
territoires oui aussi et bien sûr à
l'aide de la recherche mais à condition
que on se met franchement dans la double
mission de de la croissance de demain
ce qui n'a pas été fait pour la grèce
d'un côté et de la discipline budgétaire
de l'autre alors bien sûr que ça mettra
du temps mais si on met pas la grèce
porter
par ces deux piliers fondamentaux
l'organisation de la rigueur budgétaire
d'un côté et de l'autre côté une
capacité de relance bien on n'aura
jamais la possibilité de retrouver la
grèce sur les marchés financiers pour la
france s'il y a aujourd'hui une position
du gouvernement
initié par le président de la république
c'est bien de dire il ya une règle d'or
et elles les dépenses d'avenir
souvenons nous de ce débat sur les
dépenses d'avenir folle et faut-il les
faut-il pas affolé faut-il hauteur de 30
40 50 70 milliards 100 milliards
rappelons-nous de du rapport rocard
juppé
rappelons-nous de l'expression qui m'a
eu beaucoup plus 35 milliards c'est
l'épaisseur du trait c'est l'épaisseur
du trait de la dette en plus pour une
relance
regardons la façon dont on utilise ces
35 milliards
il ya des projets ils sont retenus ils
sont sur des jurys internationaux dont
personne ne conteste la qualité et qui
nous permettent de d'avancé sur ce que
sera la croissance de demain en france
qui est une croissance qui sera basée
sur l'innovation et sur la recherche et
donc d'avoir et sur l'université et
d'avoir choisi donc ces axes là ça ça
présage effectivement que oui bien sûr
la france est en difficulté comme tous
les pays endettés mais en même temps il
ya derrière une relance sur un objectif
particulier ciblée et j'espère que ce
qui a été fait pour la grèce ce que la
france a décidé courageusement de faire
pour son pays
eh bien ça sera aussi décider au niveau
européen parce que le prochain budget et
les prochains budgets 6 et des budgets à
la fois autonome qui tirent leurs
recettes d'une taxe sur les transactions
financières qu'elle ne tenait plus dans
cette situation un peu schizophrénique
dans laquelle on demande au parlement
français parlements des états membres de
voter une ligne budgétaire sans corps
brisé la capacité de dire à quoi est
destiné
cette ligne puis ensuite deuxième
frustration que les députés européens et
sous les yeux la ligne budgétaire
encadré sur laquelle ils peuvent
uniquement ventilé l'ensemble des
dépenses
je trouve qu'il ya là permettez moi de
le dire qui était longtemps
parlementaire et et qui espèrent les
trolls à nouveau un jour que dans le
contexte
oui je sais pas si vous me le souhaitez
ou pas vous le souhaitez et il ya comme
dans toute l'europe des avantages et des
inconvénients
c'est à dire que bon je l'inviterai les
commentaires dans le dans ce contexte là
le fait de dire il arrive au niveau
européen
quelque chose qui est indépendant des
états membres ça veut dire que on est
plus dans la logique du du juste retour
de dudu aouate my money back de anglo
saxon du chèque du chèque britannique de
de la volonté de retrouver au travers de
fonds structurels ou de fonds de
cohésion
l'argent qui a été investi et et cette
obsession que nous avons quand on dit la
france a donné 18 milliards combien
combien on a eu en retour
et oui mais combien l'europe peut-elle
gagner en croissance si on trouve que ce
budget souriante non plus vers un retour
juste et injuste mais plutôt vers une
croissance qui est profitable à
l'ensemble et qui ne nous oblige pas un
jour à être dans l'aide d'un autre pays
d' est à membres parce que il n'a pas
effectué les réformes nécessaires pour
obtenir la croissance et pays qui sont
en forte croissance regardez la suède
regardez regardez danemark
regardez regardez l'allemagne regardez
le canada c'est les pays qui sont passés
par départ des phases ou à un moment
donné ils ont fait ce double choix le
choix de l'avenir la croissance le choix
de la rigueur est arrivé à maintenir les
deux j'ai l'habitude
marc daunis
le c'est d'avoir un rallye antibes et
j'ai toujours vu les grands compétiteurs
m'expliquer que pour bien effectuer de
la vitesse dans une route sinueuse il
fallait savoir appuyer à la fois sur le
frein et sur l'accélérateur et bien
c'est pas facile mais c'est probable ans
comme ça qu'on part pas dans le décor et
qu'on arrive à terme
l'accélérateur de la relance et de la
croissance et la rigueur du frein
budgétaire c'est les deux éléments qui
doivent nous nous guider à la fois dans
la politique européenne et peut-être
bien que ce ne soit pas l'objet de mon
propos dans la politique française
contre partie de l'italie que l'italie
met en place ce pourquoi elle s'est
engagée
c'est ça la vraie contre contrepartie
monsieur courteau il n'y a pas de
contrepartie particulière mais je crois
que le message a bien été rappelés y
compris en conférence de presse par le
président français et la chancelière
allemande
effectivement la solidarité où la
générosité sans le contrôler
c'est la faillite des états c'est la
grèce
la rigueur sans la solidarité c'est la
récession et la misère des peuples
les deux associés la rigueur discipline
budgétaire et la solidarité pour la
croissance
ça c'est peut-être effectivement
l'efficacité que l'on peut espérer pour
l'europe et pour notre pays
mais merci monsieur ministre avant de
avant avant qu'une nouvelle série de
collègues
vous interroge encore que vous avez été
jusqu'à présent extrêmement complet moi
je voudrais faire une remarque de
remarques teintée d'inquiétude
c'est ce que je sais pas si c'est la
mode mais enfin c'est l'air du temps à
sur sur ce que vous avez indiquée au
sujet des défauts structurels européens
de la politique de cohésion
puisque nous sommes dans une période
d'élaboration du budget européen pour la
période 2014 2020
oui et au niveau de la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat nous
sommes très attentifs à ce sujet et nous
avons avant l'été votez à mon initiative
et à celle de yann gaillard sénateur de
l'aube une proposition de résolution
soutenant
la notion de régions intermédiaires et
oui non mais c'est pas ça me fait pas
sourire
non mais ça me fait sourire parce que
c'est un sujet complexe et c'est
monsieur le ministre votre unanime du
sénat donc je crois que ça doit être
pris ça doit être pris en compte et ça
suivait et ça suivait un rapport que
nous avions élaboré aussi avec le même
colin collègues conjointement sur
l'avenir de la politique de cohésion est
ce que vous avez indiquée sur la main
sur l'utilisation des fonds structurels
andres je voudrais pas que ce soit un
argument de plus pour pour réduire la
part de cette politique dans le budget
européenne donc voilà je souhaitais
marqué un peu le coup et puis je vais
donner la parole à d'autres collègues
puis vous me répondrez comme aux autres
collègues ensuite qui donne la parole
monsieur delebarre pour aller dans le
sens de ce que je viens de dire le
président monsieur le ministre
certes un bon esprit européen
je crains que dans ces bons esprits 10
et la chancelière et le président de
république française imagine que si un
pays
pardon en début de votre intervention
mme smith a mais vous savez en venant au
sénat je fais des progrès je reviens
donc sur ces bons esprits
ils ont imaginé que si un pays ne
respectaient pas les engagements
fondamentaux
il pourrait exister des mesures de
rétorsion sur la politique de cohésion à
l'égard des régions de ce pays qui ne
respecteraient pas
c'était non pas du tout crois pas du
tout que ce soit le bon sens c'est à
dire que on va faire payer à des régions
qui ne sont pas nécessairement coupable
de la position nationale du pays on va
faire payer en rendant plus difficile
leur développement parce qu'on leur
supprime quand des éléments de la
politique de cohésion parce que le
niveau national ne s'est pas bien
conduit je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
bonne pratique quand on veut essayer de
jouer le développement de ces
territoires et du pays
donc cela m'inquiète machado nice juste
une petite remarque d'abord préliminaire
je crois qu'il est heureux que les
banques françaises aient une
recapitalisation autonome au vu de ce
qu'elles le sont distribués comme
dividendes ne serait-ce que l'année
dernière je crois qu'il aurait été assez
mal compris qu'il en soit autrement
je ferme la parenthèse simplement
mais oui une deuxième petite remarque
vous avez pas mais monsieur le ministre
de dette insoutenable
je crois que le concept est quand même
assez délicat à manier
parce que c'est ce que c'est le montant
ou la nature des regards le montant
proportionnel
on regarde la dette japonaise
on est sur une toute autre échelle de
valeur et la grande différence c'est
quand même que je crois de mémoire plus
de 60% de la dette en question est
détenu par ge et japonais eux-mêmes ce
qui rend la nature de la dette
différentes et non pas que le montant
donc cette notion de dette insoutenable
à quel moment considère qu'elle
insoutenable et par rapport à quels
critères
je crois que ça mériterait d'être un peu
éclairci et travailler d'autant plus que
si c'est ce qui doit justifier après une
spéculation sur la dette et que cette
spéculation puisse être livré sans qu'il
y ait des régulateurs efficace ça
mériterait effectivement que l'on s'y
attarde quelque peu vous avez parlé de
temps couple discipline solidarité est
ce que vous ne craignez pas qu'il reste
la discipline et que la solidarité
quelques difficultés à se mettre en
oeuvre 6 1
vous avez parlé de croissance de demain
sur l'innovation et la recherche
on sait très bien que cette croissance
de demain autour de l'innovation
conséquence des novations et la
recherche demande pour être traduit en
politique industrielle des liquidités
premier problème nous sommes aujourd'hui
confrontés à ce problème des liquidités
qui va train pour la croissance
2e deuxième conséquence est ce qu'on
peut parler de ce fameux coup discipline
solidarité sans une taxation sur les
transactions financières est à voir en
la matière une politique qui soit au
niveau européen
accepter pour que l'on puisse avoir
paradoxalement j'ai à dire les moyens de
la politique et enfin je suis persuadé
que la question des euro-obligations
n'aura pas été oubliés toujours dans les
négociations qui sont conduites jusqu'à
6 min si vous avez un éclaircissement
sur sept derniers points
monsieur benoît huré mais non je pense
avoir heurté un peu notre collègue
ministre delvar quand je disais que
c'était le bon sens peut-être que le mot
n'était pas forcément approprié mais si
vous n'avez pas un minimum de règles on
se retrouve vite dans les zapa ce que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui est comment
imaginer cette construction qui ferait
que des régions d'un même pays serait
victime du comportement de l'état je
pense que les choses sont plus en plus
imbriquées parce que quand on est région
on est aussi pays est en tous les cas je
crois qu'il faut qu'ils aient cette
cette menace a alors à ce moment là pour
que les autorités régionales d'un pays
soit suffisamment vigilante et exigeante
vis-à-vis de leur état ou de leur
gouvernement comme et on peut pas
imaginer ne pas avoir ce au moins mettre
en avant ce risque de de rétorsion et ce
à partir des fonds structurels par
exemple si on ne respecte pas la règle
parce que le système va explosera très
rapidement et connaîtra vite ses limites
d'autres interventions avant de laisser
le ministre nous répondre non monsieur
le ministre
merci de ces questions extrêmement
pertinente quelques complexes pour
répondre en sens inverse directement à
mesurer la force sans la justice c'est
la tyrannie et la justice en la force
c'est l'impuissance
c'est pas de moi c'est de pascal c'est
quand même quelque chose qui doit nous
inspirer dans nos politiques qui doivent
être équilibrés et paraît logique qu'on
évoque effectivement cette cette
contrainte pour connais pas en prenant
un taxi en bretagne le chauffeur taxi
qui vous disent monsieur on fait de la
politique vous surtout ne nous fait pas
payer pour les grecs ils ont triché et
que cette phrase populaire ne devienne
pas une vague populiste qui s'étendent à
l'intérieur comme je le vois aujourd'hui
de l'allemagne avec nous avons fait
l'effort nous avons absorbé l'allemagne
de l'est
nous avons à restructurer tout notre
organisation sociale
nous avons mis des plans de rigueur en
place nous avons un euro fort parce que
nous avions un mark fort et aujourd'hui
vous nous demandez de d'être solidaires
de ceux qui n'ont pas fait l'effort
nécessaire
vous le savez c'est pas la position de
la france d'abandonner la grèce est donc
cette solidarité là elle ne peut pas ne
pas ça sortir d'une certaine discipline
pour les perspectives financières les
perspectives financières deux sujets un
premier sujet global et perspectives
financières ne peuvent pas s'affranchir
des situations des états membres les
états membres tous les états membres est
probablement plus ailleurs qu'en france
subissent violemment les contrecoups de
la crise et tous ont des plans de
discipline de rigueur budgétaire
je vous rappelle que la l'espagne est à
21 % de chômage que le salaire des en
grande bretagne a baissé de 30% que ce
même pays a licencié 500 mille
fonctionnaires que le salaire les
salaires ont baissé dans la plupart des
pays de la zone euro et même dans pas
uniquement en république tchèque ou en
roumanie mais aussi au danemark
c'est dire que on se trouve dans une
situation où il est quand même difficile
de dire ici à budget rigueur parce que
c'est l'état et au gouvernement de
l'état membre est ici il ya budget
ouvert parce que on est dans l'europe
sans qu'on ait fait l' expertise a fait
qu'une expertise véritable c'est celle
de la pac et on l'a fait plusieurs fois
on n'a pas fait l'expertisé de la
politique de cohésion
on n'a pas fait les expertises de la
politique de recherche donc que l'on
réfléchisse des situations qui sont des
situations nouvelles qu'on ne coupe pas
les crédits indé des politiques qui sont
menées depuis longtemps et qui ont
montré aussi l'intérêt qu'elle avait
pour les peuples
mais je le répète ce ministre constatons
que quand même
la grèce a bien mal utilisés ou profiter
des aides qu'on lui apporter dans ce
domaine parce que elle a utilisé la
solidarité mais elle n'a pas utilisé la
relance elle apparaît vous réfléchi à 60
du sculpteur est dans une situation dans
laquelle il y avait une croissance
mondiale ça ne se voit pas partir du
moment où ils arrivent le grain de sable
de la crise internationale
les économies qu'ils étaient
soit dans des bulles spéculatives comme
l'irlande ou l'espagne soit dans des
situations de dette insoutenable
monsieur d'aunis à ce moment là le
problème arrive vite à à créer des
situations de crise de l'aggravation de
crise qu'est ce que c'est qu'une dette
insoutenable c'est une dette que c'est
pas le volume de la dette
vous avez bien raison c'est la capacité
du pays à répondre à cette lettre
si vous regardez la dette de l'italie
par exemple elle et par elle pas si
volumineuse que ça allait oui elle et
elle est importante mais sur la
troisième économie
le pose pas de problème mais si vous
mettez en perspective une croissance
négative une chute des du commerce
extérieur alors là oui vous dites ah oui
mais la dette elle n'était pas si
importante que ça tant qu'il y avait une
croissance mais en période de récession
et si la période de récession est
prolongée mais on se trouvera devant une
une dette qui effectivement est
insoutenable
c'est pour ça que la grèce a une dette
insoutenable elle est en récession
elle a pas de commerce extérieur elle
n'a pas de politique de croissance qui a
été mise en place
la pâte d'organisation de collecte de
l'impôt même pour ceux qui devraient ou
pourraient le payer
et enfin elle a une dette qui est à 180
5 % de son pib
donc tout ça fait que c'est l'ensemble
de la congestion qui dit oui
l epa n'est pas soutenable pas prendre
d'autre d'autres comparaisons mais la
dette américaine est gigantesque et
pourtant soutenable pour des raisons qui
sont différentes c'est que le dollar
étant les états unis étant eux mêmes les
producteurs de dollars ils peuvent
trouver les moyens de faire en sorte que
leur dette soient soutenant donc
l'insoutenabilité c'est parce qu'il ya à
votre porte quelqu'un qui frappe qui est
qui demande le solde ou qui ne croient
plus que le solde que vous puissiez
donner votre
outre rembourser votre dette et est qui
et qui dégradent votre note mais un mot
sur les agences de notation sur lesquels
j'ai dit beaucoup de balles et je ne le
regrette pas mais pourtant en regardant
avec une certaine décidé c'est un
thermomètre qui mesurent la fièvre le
thermomètre est pas très bon mais c'est
pas en cassant le thermomètre que roy
plus de fièvre et en même temps les
l'organisation tel que le propose et la
france au niveau européen qui est
surveillance la déclaration des critères
objectifs nécessaires et de l'absence de
nos pas si tu es sûre les décisions
prises fait que on a besoin aussi d'un
genre de notation une agence de notation
si rien d'autre que un élément extérieur
qui dit je suis pas sûr que vous alliez
vous avez payez votre dette
et comme je ne suis pas sûr dans le
contexte actuel que vous avez payez
votre dette
je montre le taux d'intérêt il faut dire
que c'est bien sûr qui fragilisent les
économies mais franchissent les
économies endettées et si les économies
n'était pas aussi endetté le poserait
pas de problème les agences de notation
jamais posé un problème en allemagne
donc soyons forts pour ne pas se trouver
face à la spéculation plutôt que
d'essayer de supprimer d'un trait de
plume la spéculation nous n'y avons pas
et vous avez parfaitement raison de dire
que la taxation des transactions
financières et une des solutions
majeures et le président la république a
dit c'était une obligation morale
économique et politique morale et
politique parce que ça n'est pas
complètement anormal que l'origine de la
crise même si elle se perd un peu dans
la nuit des temps avec lehman brothers
et qu'elle n'était pas tout à fait de
même nature c'est quand même les marchés
financiers et que ce soit le prélèvement
sur les marchés financiers qui n'ont
rien à voir avec l'économie réelle
qu'ils viennent en partie financé la
situation dégradée dans laquelle se
trouve l'ensemble des états c'est une
bonne réponse au populisme c'est une
bonne réponse à ce qu'ils disent est
alors eux ils payent quand ils payent
par la transaction n'est pas la taxe des
transactions financières
en même temps si si de 20 à 70 milliards
selon les hypothèses rentrer dans le
budget de l'europe
ça donne la possibilité d'apporter la
croissance d'apporter la relance après
tout peut-être qu'on peut imaginer
de manière un peu manichéenne et ce
n'est jamais comme ça que ça se passe
que les états membres appliquent la
discipline contrôler et puis que
l'europe s'occupe de l'avenir et que
elles mutualisent en subsidiarité
un peu comme dans une intercommunalité
l'intérêt général tout en préservant les
intérêts particuliers et qu'elle le
fasse donc la croissance nécessaire pour
demain volontiers
le commissaire au budget indique que si
la taxe est institué et qu'elle a un
produit
sa proposition sera que ce produit se
substitue aux recettes actuelles de
l'union que ce ne soit pas une recette
supplémentaire et indiqué que la
position du gouvernement français à cet
égard une bonne occasion d'aller donner
la bonne réponse
aujourd'hui le gouvernement français dit
qu'il faut substituer des recettes
propres européennes à la contribution
des états membres
ça fait zéro mais ça fait une dynamique
ça peut même faire au moins non ça fera
pas moins mais en tout cas que sa vie
est leur déduction de la contribution
des états membres qui sont dans une
situation budgétaire difficile ça n'est
pas non plus totalement irrationnel et
qu'en même temps on retombe sur
l'économie sur le sur le sur le second
imaginé initialement et qu'on dise
ben je veux pas comme un moine et
reviennent aucun argent revienne
il n'y a pas de juste retour puisque le
retour est moindre puisque la
contribution a été moindre
c'est aussi un cercle vertueux qui se
met en place en tout cas en tout cas sur
le plan moral et politique
je crois que tout le monde peut être
d'accord sur le plan économique
ça vient en déduction des états membres
donc ça vient un allègement des budgets
que ce soit le budget européen où le
budget
des états membres j'ai bien noté que
toute recette obtient rapidement une
affectation multiples et cumulatives
voilà mes attendant elle atteint dormait
alors mettant l'homme est en larmes
place et puis justement ce niveau là
vous pensez vraiment que les anglais
vont accepter non voilà c'est ça non
quelle est la possibilité de mettre en
place
si un refus absolu d'aider anglais ou au
conseil au g20 y aura un refus des ans
des clés il refuse anglais probablement
des suédois y aura un problème un
problème de ce type
ça peut être envisagée ça veut dire
qu'il faut trouver le taux suffisamment
bas pour que le déplacement des places
financières se fasse pas et que pour
autant qu il y ait une recette
substantielle sera dans la zone euro
voilà à la fois trouvèrent on va le
proposer dans le cadre du g20 dont
si l'ensemble des pays du monde en
veulent pas proposera dans le cadre
européen
si l'ensemble des pays hors europe et un
envol par proposera dans la zone euro
sans reprendre le débat qu'on a vu la
semaine dernière
est ce qu'une des questions justement
par rapport au g20 par rapport à cette
taxation
c'est pas justement à quoi sera imputé
cette recette
et si on veut créer des dédits mondiaux
il faut aussi que les pays du sud voit
passer une partie de la recette c'est
peut-être comme ça qu'on peut sortir
également des logiques purement euros je
ne vais pas m'avancer sur l'affectation
d'une recette qui n'existe pas mais six
à rendre le budget européen le budget
européen il a une politique de
développement
il a une politique d' aide au fonds
européen il a une politique des de
cohésion et une positif de fonds
structurels et les politiques sur la
recherche restera c'est plus facile
d'affecter la recette que de l'obtenir
monsieur bailly une dernière
une dernière question puisque j'étais un
peu surpris s'il vous plaît j'étais un
peu surpris du ministre quand vous avez
des yé la mauvaise utilisation des fonds
structurels a par exemple situation de
la grèce on peut on peut critiquer une
gestion interne sur une fiscalité mais
sur quelle analyse sur quelle évaluation
vous vous basez pour tenir une telle
appréciation
maintenant ce qu'on voit un pays qui est
rentré dans la zone euro déjà beaucoup
depuis plusieurs années qu'ils
rentraient dans l'europe depuis très
longtemps et donc à bénéficier d'une
aide depuis les années 80 et que l'on
constate aucune économie de marché à
l'intérieur on peut se poser la question
si l'argent par exemple le fonds
structurels qui arrive aujourd'hui de 8
milliards
il est destiné à organiser
l'administration à l'intérieur du pays
est ce que est ce qu'un pays qui est
dans l'europe dans la zone euro qui a la
culture le patrimoine et le passé de la
grèce
n'aurait pas pu utiliser cet argent pour
faire en sorte qu'ils organisent un état
qu'il organise un état une
administration d'état qui soit capable
de contrôler et d'évaluer de réagir
et puis même dire il ya pas de rien pas
de thabo pourquoi il y aurait pas de
d'activités de recherche de
développement d'industries dans le
territoire grec rien et ce pays est
incapable d'exporter quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui pour ça que lorsque l'on dit
ils ont qu'à retourner aux dragons comme
ça ils auront une grande compétitivité
pour avoir la compétitivité voire de
l'exportation n'est pas d'exportation à
quoi ça vous sert d'avoir une
compétitivité une dévaluation de votre
monnaie ça sert qu'à pouvez re appauvrir
les peuples donc je dis pas que c'est la
faute au peuple grec je dis même pas que
c'est la faute aux dirigeants
c'est aussi la faute à l'europe qui
appliquée à ce moment là la distribution
dans une période de croissance sans se
préoccuper de l'avenir qui pouvait être
plus incertain enfin et toujours facile
de faire les comptes à rebours est de
refaire le passé à la lumière du présent
accord mais constatons qu aujourd'hui
ces fonds
quand on les vallées verser les 8
milliards à côté des huit milliards de
de dead les 8 milliards de fonds
structurels
essayons de faire en sorte que les
experts l'utilisent pour organiser ce
pays et
cibler ses dépenses vers la croissance
de demain
sinon on se retrouvera dans le tonneau
des danaïdes très grec
les eurobonds monsieur c ur joie ça non
mais c'est toujours comme ça christophe
parisot
ça me fait bondir les eurobonds voilà je
disais l'autre jour mon nom est bond
rebonds
chez à partir de là le permis à d'aller
sur le marché
mais j'ai aussi le permis de de prendre
des risques
qu'est ce que c'est en fait les
eurobonds vous savez tous ici c'est la
mutualisation immédiate de la dette
la mutualisation immédiate de la dette
c'est le fait de se trouver de
convaincre l'allemagne de se trouver
avec le même titre d'émission de dette
que la grèce la france aussi je suis pas
sûr que ce soit quelque chose qui puisse
être exposée de cette façon en revanche
si ça doit pas être l'élément initial ça
peut être l'élément final qu'est ce que
c'est que le montage finalement le fonds
européen de stabilisation financière qui
garantirait sous le sceau le biais d'un
véhicule la possibilité d'assumer 10 20
30 % de la dette souveraine des états
c'est assumer un la garantie de titre de
bons de trésor de dette souveraine de
pays en six titres en situation de
difficulté donc moi pour les eurobonds
non mais le problème le problème est
toujours de savoir quand est ce qu'on
fait si on fait comme mort il a été
proposé immédiatement la mise en place
de rebond elle n'a pas elle n'a pas
d'intérêt et le risque de dégrader la
note des eurobonds concerné je vous
rappelle qu'il ya une agence de notation
qui a dit qu'elle par sécurité est le
lait classerait avec la même cotation
que la dette grecque
donc ça c'est quand même un élément
qu'on ne peut pas ne pas prendre en
compte
ça veut dire que pour la france c'est
une augmentation de ces crédits pour
l'allemagne aussi de co2 de ses taux
d'intérêt pour l'allemagne c'est 5
milliards par an est ce qu'on peut faire
accepter ça pour la france ces 2
milliard est ce qu'on peut faire
accepter ça dans un budget en disant on
va créer des obligations européennes
et effectivement ça calmerait le marché
je dirais même que le marché le réclame
marché serait très heureux de changer
des obligations portugaises contre des
obligations européennes garanties par
l'allemagne l'apprend la france et donc
on ferait paradoxalement le jeu de
marché qu'au bout du compte on se
retrouve dans une situation où en
solidarité
après avoir organisé la discipline et
les piliers ou les murailles comme vous
voulez de la défense contre la
spéculation on puisse dire maintenant on
a mis en place sa discipline on a mis en
place les éléments de solidarité
le fonds européen de stabilité
financière peut intervenir à hauteur
importante dissuadant toutes actions
spéculatives
on a en même temps restructurer la dette
grecque et
les banques l'on assume et on peut
envisager à ce moment là que les
euro-obligations arrive elle arrive
d'ailleurs vous l'avez compris dans le
contexte d'une europe intégrée
comment pourrait-on imaginer des
eurobonds si on n'était pas dans une
europe intégrée économiquement intégré
et avec une harmonisation fiscale et
j'ose le mot en partie sociale parce que
quand même difficile d'envisager que un
peuple que je ne nommerai pas et qui à
son niveau de retraite à 67 ans se met à
émettre des eurobonds en faveur de notre
peuple que je ne nommerai pas mais qui a
une retraite à 60 ans je suis désolé de
le dire aussi brutalement et peut-être
que le premier ministre un jour là dit
un peu maladroitement mais la
convergence l'harmonisation de
l'économie ça n'est pas uniquement
larmes que l'harmonisation d'une
économie fiscale c'est obligatoirement
un socle est d'ailleurs la france le
défendre comme un socle au niveau du g20
un socle de 2,2 de sécurité sociale au
sens de socle social garanti qui
permettent effectivement de dire voilà
ça c'est le minimum qu'on impose à
l'ensemble des peuples s'ils veulent
aller plus loin ils peuvent aller plus
loin et s'ils en ont les possibilités
c'est leur choix mais il doit y avoir
aussi un plancher de garantie sociale
sur l'ensemble des pays européens
et c'est une des propositions qu'il faut
aussi faire on peut pas non plus
expliquer au peuple que tout se fait
dans l'économie dans la finance ça se
fait aussi dans le social ça se fait
aussi dans la croissance
ça se fait aussi dans l'emploi la raison
pour laquelle l'ensemble de ce
dispositif fait que lorsqu'on aura
intégré une partie de notre économie
si nous l'acceptons bain
ça veut dire qu'on aura conservé la
liberté de ne pas être soumis aux
spéculateurs mais que cette liberté elle
ça sortira d'une discipline
communautaire qui fera en sorte quand
même moment donné on se mettra des
règles et que la règle d'or imposera
d'autres règles ultérieure je ne traîne
pas là l'enthousiasmé des foules lorsque
je dis cela mais je vous promets
réveiller dans l'esprit de chaque
parlementaire le fait qu' il ya quand
même la convergence s'est pas uniquement
la convergence fiscale sur les régions
les régions intermédiaires rappelons
simplement que la france défend les
quitter
chaque région au même niveau doit avoir
le même possibilité est donc qu'est ce
que ça veut dire intermédiaire si
lorsqu'elle soit entre 75% et 90%
elles sont dans une région dans une zone
intermédiaire qui leur permet d'amortir
le fait qu'elles sont passées à une
étape différente et qu'elle ne perde pas
brutalement les possibilités des
européennes c'est une logique
si par contre on sécurise que à cet
endroit celles qui étaient au dessous et
qui passe au dessus
conservez conserve les moyens mais
celles qui étaient déjà au dessus ne
l'ont pas et à une inéquité évidente
entre les régions et si on dit il ya une
régions intermédiaires qui se trouve
entre 115 90 et qui ne correspond pas
uniquement aux régions qui sortent des
critères de convergence
eh bien on se trouvera obligatoirement
dans une situation de disparités de un
petit mot de monsieur emorine et après
on conclu avec ce que nous avons entendu
pendant une heure et demie peu plutôt
nous inquiéter
je vous rappellerai aime chez mini ça je
souhaite c est ce que jean monnet
pouvait dire l'important dans la vie
n'est pas d'être pessimiste ou optimiste
c'est d'être déterminé à ce que souhaite
surtout c'est que vous soyez déterminé
vu qu'en colère
merci monsieur le président oui tout
d'abord je remercie de jeu donne la
parole de repas le faire je suis désolé
c'est anciennes habitudes de par le
monde
non mais je vous remercie de cet échange
tous les cas mais je suis persuadé qu'on
aura l'occasion de vous revoir parce que
les choses ne sont pas aussi simples
je veux parler à la fois des taxations
financières je ne sais pas techniquement
comment on le fait c'est sur quel
périmètre
parce que quand françois marque nous dit
que 75 % échappent des transactions
échappent à la régulation ça veut dire
que la taxation à la limite ne porterait
que sur 25 % et encore je donc l'idée au
niveau moral je la comprends très bien
je j'adhère pleinement je ne sais pas le
faire techniquement ça fait penser à
hadopi cette histoire c'est qu'on aura
toujours un métro de retard par rapport
aux flingueurs enfin à tous ceux qui
contournent toutes les règles je pense
que la technique est las de transactions
à la nanoseconde nous et ne devancera à
chaque fois la deuxième c'est sur les
eurobonds death et là je pense qu'on
devrait avoir
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait un débat réel
sur sur cette faisabilité d'abord et est
ce que on ne se tire pas une balle dans
le pied en la faisant enfin quel est le
périmètre qui joue un autrement dit on
évoque l'angleterre etc
le royaume-uni bon est ce que c'est le
périmètre de l'euro est ce que c'est le
périmètre de l'union européenne comment
ça je mets en place ni à plein de
questions là dessous sur lequel en tous
les cas c'est pas ce soir qu'on va
régler ça mais je vous remercie de cette
prêté en tous les cas ce jeu de
questions et de réponses
en attendant de marthe si demain était
la pentecôte ce serait pas mal
je ne crois pas que l'esprit-saint
descendra sur le président de la
république mais je pense quand même que
on devrait pouvoir avoir de bonnes
nouvelles qui montre la détermination de
la france dans la construction
européenne
la spree 16 sur la tête du président de
la république on aura entendu deux rôles
de choses à dire comme si sa cheville
je vous rappelle moi je voudrais
moi moi je voudrais pas moi qui les ai
moi je voudrais vous remercier vous
connaissez parfaitement vos dossiers
vous avez des idées arrêtées parfois
parfois j'ai trouvé mon par le vent h 20
un peu trop mois sur deux sujets je
trouve que vous avez été un peu dur avec
la grèce mais je suis partisan puisque
je suis le président du groupe d'amitié
de ce pays mais quand même quand même
quand même qu'à même quand même ce pays
à une troïka
il ya maintenant des experts européens
qui sont sur place bon c'est quand même
pays européennes c'est pas il faudrait
pas qu'on revienne à des errements à ce
qu'on a connu dans les rapports entre
entre peuples entre nations il ya il ya
un certain nombre d'années
je les ai trouvés un peu dur et puis je
pense que quand on est mais des
critiques
il faut aussi examiner soi même et je
pense qu'on n'est pas exempte de toute
critique et on est loin d'être parfait
ensuite vous m'avez inquiéter un peu
inquiété c'est être pas le but mais on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler puisque le
débat sur le l'élaboration du budget
européen va se poursuivre dans cette fin
d'année sur le semestre 2012 mais sachez
que la politique de cohésion
territoriale elle est très importante
pour nos collectivités pour nos
départements pour nos régions pour nos
communes
la notion de régions intermédiaires ce
n'est pas nous qui l'avons demandé c'est
le commissaire européen johannes hahn
qui le propose au nom de la commission
il ya l'accord du parlement européen et
nous sommes un peu chagrin toutes
tendances politiques confondues de voir
le gouvernement français un peu à la
traîne à ce sujet non à la traîne à
monsieur le ministre
donc l' avantage des parlementaires ce
qui vous reçoivent c'est d'avoir le
dernier mot donc moi je voulais insister
insisté
je voulais insister d'insister sur ces
insisté sur ces deux poèmes et puis vous
remercier à nouveau de votre
disponibilité je crois que nos collègues
ont été très intéressés à cet échange
qui se renouvellera nous en sommes
certains
merci encore vous venez de suivre
l'audition de jean leonetti si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous avec
elle les travaux parlementaires cet
après midi 16h30 avec l examen du projet
de loi de renforcement de la sécurité
sanitaire il s'agit de la suite de la
sphère média tort très bonne journée à
tous